ihr habt eingeschaltet zu meinem
allerersten blog endlich so oft kamen
die nachfeier kg warum machst du mal
einen blog und nimmst du es mal mit das
ding ist auf instagram habe ich schon
ganz viel gezeigt denn auch in hamburg
war schalke gegen dortmund und ich bin
gerade hier um euch eine kanutour zu
geben dass es die neue wohnung auf
instagram konnte ich euch ja schon
zeigen aber nicht alle sind auf
instagram deswegen gehe ich mal die
kamera und sie kenne hier image der
küche es ist eine wohnküche das habe ich
bewusst so ausgelegt weil wir ganz viel
platz brauchen zum drehen und weil wir
hier also quasi hier eine küchen insel
haben wollen oder eine küche in u form
sodass ich dass ich hier für euch
richtig gute videos abliefern kann
hier kommt dann also unsere küchenzeile
hin mit ganz schön hoch schränken hier
seht ihr noch die balance von 100k
special
das foto haben wir hier gemacht und
lasst euch hier dran bitten die sterne
haben soll wollte ursprünglich hier
fußballgucken in seiner kino atmosphäre
war wohl nix hamza warum wir also unser
erster block und schon eine
anschuldigung besonders frechheit so
lustig heftet ich bin total glücklich
mit unserer wohnsituation hier ist alles
wirklich alles das einzige was wir dass
die kräfte sind dass die mühle sind
trauen das wäre ein
ja ich kann hier super kochen und
genießen denn männer zu viel träumen
[Musik]
ich möchte nicht in den duden können wir
irgendwas anderes so ich zeige euch
jetzt noch mal die anderen räume
vielleicht ist sehr interessant für euch
hier zum beispiel nennt falsches licht
also direkt neben der wohnküche ist
unser büro das ist so ein kleiner raum
hier kann man so ein bisschen arbeiten
und ein paar sachen verstauen und dann
geht's den flur entlang vieles alles
noch recht katastrophe alt aus wie auch
genau das ist eher uninteressant hier
ist es badezimmer herrschaft zum
beispiel ob das ist wirklich
uninteressant und das war auch schon die
wohnung ist nämlich jetzt schon
abgeflossen das wasser mit dem zu lernen
der ruhm tour will dann kein internet
hat meint aufgebraucht weil er endlich
gereicht hat du solltest du nicht und
dann wird sondern müssen wir das teufel
wir nehmen euch irgendwann wieder mit
durch diesen prozess hier heute sehen
wir das einrichten das zeigen wir euch
gerne durch alle prozesse mit wenn euch
irgendwas besonders interessiert
dann schreibt sie jetzt in die
kommentare damit ich jetzt darauf
eingehen kann und ich bereue dass ich
euch dieses oder jenes nicht gezeigt
dass jemand wirklich und interessantes
ist badezimmern schlachten interessiert
mich auch wirklich niemanden aber die
küche ist so ich freue mich schon mich
darin auszudrücken oder sonst gesehen
genau die schranken
zwar genau später kommt meinen vater
noch gebaut und den spiegelschrank und
die wand die beste was das video erneut
nicht enden
ich brauche mich nicht zu euch mache ich
das gerne so zuletzt schon komisch
angeguckt sie soll ist gemacht hat aber
ich will mich jetzt auf ok einbeziehen
ich bestimmt aber ich verrate der hanse
hat mit diesem pool gekauft du hast echt
so einstellen geschmack der schurke
besucher dankeschön
eigentlich wollte was sagen dazu erst
dankeschön nicht mir dann oder teller
haben beginnt es nicht gleich ein ganzes
bündel ich weiß ich muss nochmal ich
muss mich noch mal mit den läden erster
ist man so müssen wir noch nicht so
recht
wer will kann sich jetzt ein döner und
er war glaube ich schon fünf sechs mal
bei den dass sie den stamm dünner raten
wir uns in der umgebung 14 übrigen
märkten in europa derzeit genau in die
linse reingucken genau was ich mir keine
weiß ich noch nicht so stark das ist
recht so gut weil wir wissen was genau
ich brauche noch tief auf ihn folgt man
wird echt komisch angeguckt wenn man
draußen lockt schon was ich mache ich
das habe ich kein problem mit jesse
nein ich mache mir jetzt ein thunfisch
ernst habe richtig bock drauf
ich weiß aber ich habe richtig lust auf
thunfisch rap bis gleich wieder zu hause
angekommen zeige ich euch nur unsere
aktuelle situation habe kein mitleid mit
unserem so schön dies aussieht also
haben sie da vorne
er hat so eine mega cool ich mache mich
hier so und jetzt fehlen mir nur noch
zwiebeln von deinem dünner teller was
ist mit der hand ich bin völlig
schmerzfrei und nicht zu viel auf einmal
danke auch ein bisschen okay okay ich
komme nicht mit uns
die ernährung bauen oder wobei du ein
bisschen teurer weshalb sich mainz hat
bestimmt zwei euro kostet oder 186 7
euro davon kann ich fünfmal essen oder
die verkäuferinnen am antipasti stand
war übrigens so liebt die hat uns hier
noch gefüllte peperoni dazu geschenkt
richtig richtig süß übrigens dieser
paprika der schmeckt so gut an ähnlichen
habe ich schon mal gemacht ich verlinke
euch das video mal in die infobox
perfekt bin ich jetzt mal mit eurer
familie damit anfreunden tritt so als
sitze wird auf dem tisch ich kann es von
der bäckerei holen kein problem haben
wir brauchen so etwas gleicht leute dass
es so sie haben notgedrungen seine
kapselmaschine eine alte kaffeemaschine
mit in diese wohnung genommen weil wir
hier während wir gestrichen haben gerne
kaffee trinken wollten und mein papa
kabelnetzen sind dann habe ich den auch
so ein kaffee gemacht eigentlich bin ich
ganz ehrlich schmeckte nicht wirklich
gut und man doch aber so begeistert ist
mein herz gefragt ob wir die maschine
haben ob er ihnen kaffee trinken kann
richtig süß diesem moment haben soll
unbedingt die neu gekauften handtücher
waschen will aber das nötigste und das
wichtigste vergisst wo ist der löffel
also bei mir zu hause gab es schon immer
wir müssen nur schauen von lesbischen
irgendwo muss meine suche machen
[Musik]
doch meiner verpackung mit dabei oder
also ich kenne das nicht anders ich muss
man also nicht dass er denkt wir haben
doch nicht wäsche gewaschen aber ich
kann's noch mal eine bombastische und
ich weiß ja wie viele rein kommt jetzt
also bei mir sind auch so seit ich
denken kann gibt es meist besser warum
es auf der waschmaschine deswegen haben
wir sind übrigens die sind einfach
zähneputzen liebesbeziehung ist gäbe
dann so dämlich gelb
die welt beschäftigt im endeffekt mehr
nach monaten oder selbst ein und stellen
bevor wir testen das mit monate nicht
immer stimmt da nicht
ich mache die teile ernst was machst du
so was wird also die tanne die wir
machen nicht das schaffst du das
schaffst du nicht glaube dann darauf an
sich selber nicht so
die situation ist folgende möglichkeit
den akku vor dieser wunderschönen kamera
aufladen und haben dann gemerkt dass
ganz klar drin dass das erst hamza fährt
jetzt wieder zwischen fach mag und fragt
was an der sache ist es kann natürlich
sein dass der bock jetzt beendet ist
weil man weiss ja nicht die die zukunft
ist ungewiss und überhaupt in die kamera
wieder kriegen werden nicht genau
vorgeschrieben verabschiedet kann ich
mir das jetzt nehme ich muss los ok ja
auch nicht alles mitbekommen meinte weiß
jetzt auch hier und hat beschränkt es
mal aufgerollt
worden wie die aussehen zeige ich euch
jetzt mal aufgebaut weil wir haben das
über internet
wenn ich's gezeigt wir haben für den
aufbau stadt angegebenen drei stunden
für beide teile selbst eingebrockt haben
sich an einer stunde zur echten bitter
ich zeig euch machen so das ist jetzt
der spiegel schreibt da war mir wichtig
dass man die so klappen kann dass man
seine frisur nimmt sein kopf halt von
der seite sehen kann und hier kann man
so ein bisschen was ablegen und das ist
der ganz normale wandschrank er hat auch
so eine beleuchtung genau das was kommt
genau richtig nach garsten video to
sleep so das war es jetzt aber wirklich
mit dem blog ich verabschiede mich jetzt
von euch würde mich sehr freuen wenn
immer in die kommentare schreiben
das so fahndet mit uns mit gekommen zu
sein durch den tag auch wenn ich im
prinzip nur auf mein vater sagt meine
eltern gewartet haben aber ihr könnt mir
gerne schreiben was ihr beim nächsten
mal sehen wollte genau dass ich mich
beim nächsten mal zu einem regulären
rezept wieder einschaltet